Many so-called religious believers refuse
to just follow the direction of the federal
and state governments.
Medical experts and public health experts
yesterday.
And they filled the churches on what was Easter
2020.
One place where this was particularly prevalent
was the state of Kentucky.
And the governor, Andy Beshir, a Democratic
Kentucky governor.
Important detail here since it almost went
the other way.
Andy BOSHIER said if you go to church on Easter,
you will have to quarantine for 14 days to
prevent the church from becoming the nexus
of one of these super spreader events.
And it was announced that police would be
at churches recording license plate numbers.
They would be sending out a potentially sending
out misdemeanor violation orders, violation
of orders issued by state health officials
and would be forced to self-quarantine for
14 days.
Now, of course, folks like Republican Senator
Rand Paul don't like it.
Who cares what Rand Paul thinks?
He took a test for the virus and then went
to the Senate gym while the test was being
processed.
Ultimately coming out positive for Corona
virus.
So clearly, Rand Paul is not the person we
should be listening to this.
We have video of the parking lot.
And as you can see, if you're watching a full
parking lot filled with people and cars, just
like nothing is going on.
Kentucky state police did show up and put
notices like this one on people's cars, saying
that the car's presence in the parking lot
indicates the occupants are at a mass gathering,
which is currently banned for public health
reasons.
They're at risk of contracting Corona virus
and they are to self-quarantine for 14 days.
Here is video of police officers walking around,
placing the notices on vehicles.
And, of course, even media people at the church
covering this insanity ended up with those
same notices on their car saying they needed
to self-quarantine.
So do I love this?
No.
Do I want state police having to do this?
Of course not.
Public officials, health officials, police
officials, everyone's desperate.
So what do you do when people believe going
to church protects them from Corona virus?
And you immediately have all sorts of people
talking about this is authoritarian.
This is a nightmare.
This is like martial law.
People are allowed to pray and all of this
different stuff.
Come on, guys, come on.
Can't you for a second put aside that ideology
and realize we none of us like this.
But we've got to work together.
We're in this together.
And forcing police to have to do stuff like
this out of desperation is what's wrong.
We have people who either don't care or don't
believe it or can't understand what it is
that is going on.
Remember the blood of Jesus, lady?
This is a woman who was interviewed leaving
her church in Ohio.
It was maybe last week or the week before.
Remember what she had to say.
Driving out of this Ohio parking lot is a
woman who just attended a church service with
dozens of other people, including children.
May I ask you about your decision to go to
church, to be inside that?
No, I wouldn't be anywhere else.
Aren't you concerned it could infect other
people if you get sick inside?
Now people little.
Now I'm covered in blood.
I'm covered in blood.
Other people who don't go to this church who
you might encounter, all these people go to
this church, but you're going to be in places
where the grocery store every day.
I mean, people get them sick from what happened,
but they're not covered in blood.
Thank you very much.
That is weaponized, malignant ignorance.
What do you do with that?
And of course, the police I mean, you know,
if you hand out these mandatory quarantine
things to thousands of church goers, the police
don't even have the resources to actually
verify that all of those people are self-quarantine.
They just don't.
So it's not only Trump that is preventing
us from dealing with this as expeditiously
and efficiently as possible.
It's also these folks I saw video from Vancouver
over the weekend of so-called libertarians
protesting the lockdown by gathering on the
streets.
We're fighting the virus, but meanwhile, they
are fighting what they say are, you know,
authoritarian tactics to keep them home.
Some go even further, saying there's a consider
a conspiracy to hurt the economy on purpose
merely to remove Donald Trump.
So we're fighting the virus, which spreads
virally.
We're also fighting disinformation and conspiracies
and bad and or ignorant people, all of whom
seem to be viral, virally spreading their
disinformation as well.
We now heard from Dr. Foushee.
If we had started earlier and taken this more
seriously and had a concerted lockdown effort,
we would be much better off than we are today.
This is the type of stuff that I'm talking
about.